is there a moment of extending a hand
I think no there's not there is no
compromise on this issue because either
men or men and women are women or not
either biological sex exists or it
doesn't
um either it's possible for
a man to become a woman or not like
these are these are this is this is
about that that is a binary Choice it's
either it's either yes or no and any
compromise in the middle like it when
truth compromises with falsehood any any
compromise is a victory for falsehood
because any any step you take away from
the truth you are you are now in the
realm of falsehood might be degrees you
know it's like some some ideas are
crazier than others
but it's still false